this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] Uncle Joey coming at you
with Uncle Joey's joint it's brought to
you by the freeze pipe listen this is my
favorite bong on the market smoking weed
doesn't have to hurt your lungs with
freeze pipe you could save your lungs
and get a nice ice cold hit every
[__] time the pipe comes with a
detachable chamber you pop it in the
freezer for an hour when you're ready to
see the devil you pop it back on the
bung and you see the smoke pass through
the Frozen chamber making you inhale icy
cold [__] smoked and it's tremendous
you won't lose your voice you won't
cough as much it's non-toxic freezes
more quickly than water and stays Frozen
longer freeze pipe cools down the Smoke
by 300 degrees no more burning no more
coughing whether you hit a pipe a
bubbler a bong a dab or the [__] new
tornado go to freezepipe.com and
pressing code Diaz Diaz to save 10 on
your first order get your bang pipe and
bubble it today that's the
freezepipe.com and pressing code Diaz to
save 10 if you could smoke them from it
freeze pipe will make I think they got a
frozen apple coming to your house
[__] the freezepipe.com use code
Diaz d-i-a-z
the joint is also brought to you by
steps.com listen if you're on a small
business you know that every penny
counts with stamps.com you can save both
time and money on postage with premium
discounts and great rates all you need
is a computer and a printer that's it
you print the old stamps at home no
waiting in long lines at the post office
no people breathing on your neck they'll
even send you a free scale so you'll
have everything you need I personally
love stamps.com this week I had a drop
off four packages for my wife we use
stamps.com running a business isn't
cheap luckily stamps.com has huge
carrier discounts up to 84 percent off
USPS and UPS rates plus to automatically
tell you the cheapest and fastest
shipping options join the one million
businesses who trust stamps.com whether
you're small or big will help you set
your business up for Success when you
get started with stamps.com today so
sign up with promo code Joey for a
special offer includes a four-week trial
free postage and free digital scale no
long-term commitments just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and at the code Joey I
love you [__] let's get this
party started
[Music]
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here May 1st [__] Monday
and I love when the month starts on a
Monday
because you get like a [__] second
chance you know you're like okay my
April I [__] it up I got high I didn't
go to my sister's wedding you know
listen man [__] ups
they are what they are
and you [__] up you acknowledge it and
you move on then you start all over
again trust me this is from a guy who
started 80 [__] times over again
that's that was just a 98. you know what
I'm saying so give me a [__] break
here it was a great week we got a great
week coming up tremendous comes out
tomorrow listen guys I'm happy I'm happy
that it's over I'm sick of talking about
it I'm sick of dwelling in it and uh
listen it's in God's hands now that's it
I did my job
I promoted what I could I did what I had
to do
I put my store I put my heart out there
and uh
we move the [__] on to the next
[__] mind [__] speaking of Mind
[__]
and I say this in quotations I do not
have anything against the transgender
community at all at all they're growing
people want to do it who the [__] am I
to stop them that's why you do that's
why you moved to America you want to
turn into something especially now that
you're going to identify as anything you
want I could wake up tomorrow and
identify as an Asian man you know you
gotta run with it that that's the way of
the world guys and uh if you're using it
[__] use it to your advantage
a lot of people been talking about this
I didn't say nothing about it I have
nothing against the transgender
Community whatsoever you know whatever
people I don't give a [__] I'm sitting
here in New Jersey getting rain done you
think I'm over here hating on anybody
the biggest thing that's happened lately
is this Bud Light thing and
let's chit chat about this
again when I think of Bud Light
Budweiser Ford
and Isa Bush I think of when I think of
Anheuser-Busch and I see those
Clydesdales
and I think about Ford and this is as an
immigrant this is a Cuban guy that came
here in 1966 let me just tell you my
opinion
when I see Swanson's TV dinners you know
when I see McDonald's
yeah Swanson's TV dinner
it's America guys it's as American as
can be okay we all ate that Swanson's TV
dinner we [__] blood for three weeks the
little hot apple pie in the middle that
you had to release it first we and if
you didn't and the brownie if you didn't
you wouldn't grow up or or you didn't
[__] uh you know it's never too late
you want a ghost in reality go get
yourself a Swanson's hungry man [__]
dinner roast beef no the turkey with the
stuffing oh and they used to be like the
fish you would turn green after you ate
it but it didn't matter you weren't
gonna get the flu that year yeah you
know Swanson's Ford
Chevrolet you know
Cadillac when I think of Budweiser
Anheuser-Busch and all this I think of
America like
like just in in the earliest this is it
like this is American It's Never Gonna
Change it's never gonna this is the
recipe
Coca-Cola you know these things are as
American as [__] apple pie baseball
these are things that are ingrained in
people's [__] you know we all hold
something everybody hates something but
everybody likes McDonald's
you know what I'm saying I went to
McDonald a couple weeks ago for a
quarter cheese whatever the [__] they
were I was [__] starving I was
starving and I'll tell you something
that quarter pound tasted [__]
delicious I didn't go back the next day
I didn't go back the next week I was in
a pinch and there's nothing wrong with a
nice quarter pounder with a diet a Coke
Zero with a lot of ice God damn God damn
but again it's a treat for everybody
we're not talking about McDonald's here
we're not talking about Subway I don't
think of America when I see Subway all
right Blimpie I think of America
you know there's all these companies
that are just so [__] American that
leave them be
you know I was talking to you guys I
think last week or somebody I spoke to
about the movie the offer the the TV
show the offer how they made the
Godfather and throughout that movie
there's always resistance you know what
I'm saying like there's always
resistance when I used to go to meetings
in Hollywood there's always resistance
and it's resistance from one person in
the room that's negative as [__] that
likes what he likes
and you're not going to change his mind
you have to educate them to change their
mind back
what's going on in America today is a
lot of people getting jobs that don't
have experience in
I'm giving you a job as a taxi
dispatcher but you've never driven a
taxi
are you with me there's a lot of this
[__] going around you see it when you go
out to the supermarkets or restaurants
or you know we're not as experienced as
we used to [__] be and part of that
is no work no work experience no
experience in the real world like I was
telling Mike before we started the
podcast today we were talking about what
kids learn in school now that you have
so much influence now and I was telling
Mike that in about three years one of
his son's gonna come home Mike's going
to say something at the table and one of
those kids are going to go daddy that's
wrong to say and you're gonna go what I
didn't say nothing because the teachers
and the schools and all that [__] Are
Gonna woke them up a little bit okay and
whatever that means you know they're
gonna woke them up to whatever extreme
my point is that
I've been dealing with this
Ben Bell is a great Book Company
uh Netflix is great to deal with you
know all of them but there's always
those two people in the room
that aren't buying you and
those people are probably college
educated they went to a great college
and they're so stuck on their [__]
college diploma it's so far up their
[__] ass that they don't see
everything else they just Pride
themselves in being smart which they are
for that particular for book smart but
then there's a [__] Street Smart that
you get along with it and together
somewhere along the line it just clashes
you know so when I think of what's going
on with Anheuser-Busch and all these
people you know again everybody makes
eight videos
everybody's got an opinion in today's
world the ins you know
the [__] uh the web is full of
[__] uh Bud Light things I looked at
it from a business standpoint
and how they let people down who drinks
Budweiser guys
who drinks Bud Light
construction workers
I mean Budweiser to me is [__] as
American as can be my favorite beer as a
much of the hillbilly as I am I like a
cold [__] budweis I'm talking put in
the freezer for an hour and give me a
Frosted Mug there's no better bidding
Budweiser in my world but I don't like
ipas I'm not really a drinker
when I think about budweis I think about
construction guys after work you know I
think about
people from the South you know
hard-working [__] Americans you know
just like my wife they're from Tennessee
they don't know nothing when they drink
they drink on a budget
and Budweisers to be reviews yeah you
could go a little cheap and get a little
Rolling Rock or one of the other off
Brands I don't even know what beers cost
anymore but Budweiser stood for
something in this country it's not
Heineken
it's not Miller Miller Lite I [__]
hate open up a bottle of Miller Lite and
smell it you'll never drink it again it
smells like piss right off the top that
little air up in the top smells like
this but anyway this is the critique
hour I'm just talking about the common
sense
so somebody walking into Anheuser-Busch
and said let's get Bud Light
because again I have nothing against
transgenders but transgenders drink so
much Bud Light
I'm just saying let's cater it to them
did the transgender Community actually
reach out to Budweiser and say hey we
want a beer no this was somebody at
Budweiser somebody is a bush and let's
Let me give a face to this person so you
understand he's probably Young
he's probably woke
he just got out of college and he went
in there and he's a good salesman he
pitched these people
on this [__] uh transgender beer can
I don't know the story of the guy or the
girl but let me tell you something
they've lost Anheuser-Busch
has lost billions over this
like this isn't just a bad weekend
this is [__] billions I didn't know
about this guys I'm so far behind on
current events and [__] I saw all the
hoopla you know [__] Kid Rock
shooting the cans and [__]
and that's who drinks Bud Light that's
who drinks Budweiser it's something like
Kid Rock
do you really think Kid Rock or any of
those celebrities or anybody in that
world
have they ever said you know they just
they keep to themselves that's the most
quiet community there is the country
Community there's no East Coast West
Coast
rapist War there's no I hate this they
just perform they have a good time the
chicks look [__] great
so what would possess you
in this day and age to put a transgender
on you I mean people saying to invest in
[__] every other beer right now every
other like Sams
right like Sam Adams they own Corona
I'm not saying nothing about that I
could care less what the [__] you drink
you know if I go to store today if I I'm
gonna nurse for a beer I'll probably
drink a [__] Budweiser if I drink one
I've been drinking I haven't drank a
beer and
I don't know it's got to be a [__]
year maybe a Heineken the Heineken sent
me beers and I drank one of them
yeah that was the margarita I haven't
drank a [__] bed I love beer one yeah
one and I'm good because then I got a
piss 80 [__] times but I just can't
believe that they would do something
like this and nobody else is jumping on
board with it you know I'm sure
corporations I'm sure there was 10
corporations that were talking about it
they saw the debacle that happened in
Anheuser-Busch and they pushed that
[__] to the back railing right
now until they can figure this all out
again I have no hatred for budweis or
anything like that but
what were you thinking
what were you thinking just
spitting in your demographics face
and I'm not talking about
people from the South are highly [__]
religious
whatever the [__] they are seven day
evangelist whatever the [__] they are
Christians whatever
that's the second half of your [__]
beer drinking [__] escapades and
those are the people that you want to
insult
holy [__] holy anymore holy [__] I just
listen man I wish you all luck in the
world Budweiser I'm not boycotting yeah
I'm not mad at you but you [__] up
that was a big [__] [__] up
yeah I'm sure somebody's sitting down
right now with his hands tied behind his
back and there's a chubby redneck just
hitting him with a glove like you [__]
up we lost all this money because what
was the purpose of it
okay well then what are they gonna get
now I mean I'm not being an [__] but
when was the last time you seen a
transgender on a [__] Clydesdale
you know when was the last time you see
no it's it's
it's
you know you can't get mad you can just
laugh like I'm doing but it just goes to
show you where the world is going right
now it's going to a place where
sometimes you look at it and go
what the [__] is that what are they
talking about you know what it's the way
of the world it's really got nothing to
do I went to [__] Austin last week
and some the Uber driver showed me a
video I mean this guy was [__]
furious in the car Spanish Cuban guy
furious and I go what are you mad about
it this [__]
[__] those Cubans bro they [__]
they're trumpers
oh those humans are [__] trumpers
he was telling me that Biden did
something uh past our [__] law to
[__] what is that [__] when you uh
when you buy a mortgage you have to pay
40 extra to help somebody with a bad
credit rating and [__] Cubans come they
smell that that's socialism they smell
that [__] and they get [__] angry but
hey I'm not a political [__] Advocate
I don't give a [__] but why is it good
luck to you I don't know how you're
gonna get yourself out of this one you
have to put a [__] cowboy with a big
dick on the can just to get back on this
so good luck to you again I have no
hatred for budweis or anything my big
question was what the [__] were you
thinking what the [__] were you thinking
anyway I want to talk to you about
something uh one of the things I failed
to put in the book that I want to talk
to you guys about
I forgot all about it and I remembered
when I told the story a couple years ago
uh on Sickler's podcast about 1991 1990
no it was 1991 1990.
well I lived in Boulder I did time with
this guy Michael Bell and he [__]
escaped eight years later eight months
later I wasn't friends with him I knew
him I said hello to him a couple times
and he escaped and he shot four kids in
Boulder and then they shot him in the
neck and [__] uh
they shot him in the neck and they
couldn't get the bullet out so they had
to call a special surgeon and one of the
surgeons was one of the the surgeon that
they called
that guy had shot his kid killed this
kid early in the day and they wanted him
to operate a [__] tremendous story
there was a lot of crazy things going on
in Boulder in those days
before I got locked up I was enrolled at
CU Boulder as a full-time student I was
going to start
September and I got sentenced August
15th so that all fell apart
I was on campus you know and I would see
different people and I had a health and
fitness class and I became friends with
Mike Pritchard in that he was one of the
wide receivers for the Colorado
buffaloes and then I met cannabis McGee
and I met some other guys and you know I
I wasn't a big Colorado football fan
but you know what I was finally going to
go into college
they would give me a bunch of money to
go to college
and I'm like you know what man I'm gonna
be a college kid
even at 25 years old I'm gonna put a
backwards hat on and walk on campus like
a [__] college kid
and then that all ended when I got
sentenced but when I came out in 89
I waited a few months and then I said
let me go back to continuing it
and
I went to continuing ed I was selling
Subarus at the I was selling Toyotas
I was selling Toyotas and I was taking
two classes a week
and
I met you know a couple other people and
I was taking the night classes and one
of them was this girl and she was like a
trainer
she was like a tape girl you know people
put tapes on ankles and [__] on the
Colorado football team she was a dear
friend of mine her name was Joyce and
she invited me to a party one day and I
went over there and I
ended up meeting a lot of the football
players Chad Smith Chad Brown he had a
bunch of snakes and [__] in this house I
met Christian Fourier I met a bunch of
them and they were all very nice in fact
I hooked up with Christian Fourier years
later in Seattle when he played for the
the Seahawks and I was living in Seattle
he would go to swannies and he
remembered me and we talked and stuff so
I wasn't a football guy but I like those
guys I knew some of the guys in the
basketball team I knew some of the guys
in the weightlifter you know I just knew
a couple guys I didn't hang out with
them
uh shortly after I enrolled in school
I got invited to a football game like uh
when I went back to continue again I got
invited to a football game and I saw a
quarterback named Salah Nessie he was a
freshman and they drew for like three
touchdowns that [__] day two
touchdowns he was great I just somebody
invited me to a game and I went
and uh
shortly after that I was selling Toyotas
and somebody contacted me I used when I
first got to Boulder in November of 80
six
I did the job so I got a job at a car
wash the Puddle Car Wash
I worked there as a tile guy for about
three months you know it was six bucks
an hour plus tips you made about 75 a
day but you froze your [__] ass off
and you worked dog you had to wipe down
cars and vacuum and [__] it was [__]
work but you know what man I was dumb I
didn't have any plans I had no high
school diploma this is what I had to do
years later they called me back and
they're like hey man we want to talk to
you about a position over here if you
want to take it I'm not sure and then
like we want you to be our host that's
where you greet people and sell them
and I was like it's great you make like
1500 a week and you work three days a
week I was like what
in Boulder I know yeah man it's great
money and if you work five or six days a
week but you have to share the job with
this other guy so my job was to get the
other guy to quit but that was later on
this this Puddle Car Wash was one of
cu's biggest boosters the guy that owned
it his name was Howard sweetheart of a
guy his wife I worked for a guy named
Richie and there was a black dude there
that played for CU football he was just
great guy his name was Howard
and they hired me and you know I would
meet all the coaches I met Gary the
assistant offensive coordinator I met a
bunch of guys I also met the D.A at
Boulder who got me off probation after I
got out of prison in parole
I bet a lot of people that it was a
great job for me
I got to meet the McCarthy's
uh the wife and
and the coach you know nice people you
know Irish Catholics Irish my type of
[__] people she was always very nice
I didn't know nothing about nothing and
all sudden one [__] day
I hear that she's pregnant the daughter
is pregnant with the quarterback son you
know and there's a big scandal going on
in Boulder I don't give a [__] about
scandals or anything I'm just paying
attention for that and shortly after
that
was revealed that he had stomach cancer
unoperable stomach cancer this [__]
18 year old 19 year old kid
from Oceanside California who was
[__] great the reason why I'm telling
you all this because I saw the 30 for
30.
the other night I saw it was on and I
taped it I'd never seen it before
and I put it on and I had forgotten
about my time in bouldering I was just
trying to be normal guys I had gotten
the biggest Second Chance Of My Life by
being able to go to college with money
with Pell Grants and [__] you know
loans and [__] but it wasn't costing me
an arm and a leg I was proud of that you
know I was proud when I walked on the
[__] on the campus I felt like a
[__] million bucks like I'm like my
friends from Jersey
can't will never believe this that I'm
gonna see you Boulder campus not a CU
Boulder extension campus not a CU State
campus I'm at the University of Colorado
GED quit school and I'm walking around
like I own the joint you know
and it was just fun guys it and again
for me it was a mind [__]
I had forgotten who I was
I forgotten that I was just a dirty
[__] criminal from North Bergen but
it felt good just to dream you know it
always feels good just to dream you know
walking around campus and [__] like that
and uh the football team got popular and
then they lost a Notre Dame
in the championship game they made it to
the [__] Orange Bowl
and that's when I was really involved in
91 and then going into the second season
that's when Salah Messi died
and they dedicated decision to them and
they [__]
went to the Orange Bowl and they won I
was all part of that in a way like not
that I played football not that I was a
sponsor or not that I was you know I was
there
it was just so weird that I was there
for all this
and then he died and they won and you
know
you know people were [__] tearing the
coach's daughter and
it was just a bad situation it's hard to
believe
that it was 30 [__] years ago and
that that kid that they had
because I did the math lab two nights
ago he's 34 years old now that kid she
ended up having three other kids with
football players and [__] that's none of
my business she was a great sweet girl
you know God knows what her the motors
were you know I don't [__] know but
it was such a great time for me you know
like
I was a part of something that wasn't
Criminal
I mean let's face it I was faking the
funk but it was just great man it just
felt great to talk to kids and just I
don't know it was short-lived you know
uh
I went back to the University of
Colorado tried to sign up for six
credits for continuing out on the sly
just for me I didn't care about the
degree or anything at this point and I
got a letter like a month later telling
me that
I wasn't allowed off campus on campus
anymore that they would have to
call the police if I went on campus and
charged me with trespassing
because I had gotten a felony and I
wasn't allowed on campus and that guys I
don't have to tell you I mean when I was
watching this I was thinking about all
this and I had tears in my eyes because
it was
it was the end like I had this
short-lived
College [__] uh career and it
and I thought after prison that I could
just make it all go away
and walk back there like a [__] man
but
they told me uh they were gonna throw me
on and I got a lawyer and I tried taking
them to court and
it just got nowhere and then we just
made it packed listening you're not
really banned from campus but
but by that time it was too [__] late
you know but it was such a
an interesting couple years it was
something that at least it gave me
something to get up for every day and
the only regret I had with that whole
[__] time
is that I was involved in that whole
Boulder [__] kidnapping thing and the
other thing was that I really didn't
grasp of what was going on because
I was high on coke half the [__] time
you know I was the cocaine was deep deep
deep in my [__] system so
but it was uh
you know man
[Music]
I see people now like young kids and I
talk to them and they're like I'm not
going to go to college or whatever I
wish everybody goes to college I wish I
could have gone that's one of my
shortcomings and that's one of the
things I wish and I tried to take
classes at night and I looked on
schedules
it's not the same it's never going to be
the same I'm I'm glad I got the
opportunity
you know it was very [__] exciting
but can you imagine me a little CU shirt
on with books and [__] guys I was
selling it
guys I was selling them because I really
really wanted to believe
that I could [__] make this happen
real quick let's take a minute here for
a word for my [__] sponsors
Jack what's up you bad [__] to
join us brought to you by DraftKings
listen this Saturday night UFC 288 is
coming up Al Jermaine Sterling versus
sahuto you could place your bet on who
will win the bantamweight title you're
going to use DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
and they're doing it again guys new
customers can make a five dollar bet and
score 150 in bonus bets instantly you
can even take the MMA action to the next
level with DraftKings same game parlays
whether it's a decision a TKO a
submission combine multiple bets for a
shot at even a bigger [__] payout
if you're not messing around with
DraftKings you're slipping [__]
they got a happy hour every night from
six to nine
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now use code Joey but five dollars on
any UFC 288 and get 150 and bonus bets
instantly this Saturday on DraftKings
Sportsbook with Coach Joey j-o-e-y I'm
gonna take care of you now if you got a
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler if
you're in Massachusetts call
1-800-327-5050 but if you're cool listen
let's get this party started and on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort 21
plus eligible States age varies by
jurisdiction see show notes for details
DraftKings the Kings
we're back [__]
don't forget the NBA playoffs are
[__] heating up right now you got
Miami the Knicks you got [__] I I
think [__] Kansas City beat whatever
last night it don't matter NBA playoffs
are heating up download that DraftKings
you're gonna have a good [__] time I
I enter the contest that you play
roulette
and for every dollar you spend if the
Knicks and the Heat score a [__]
three-pointer you get like five bucks
so I'm hoping I'm just pulling for three
yeah who gives a [__] it cost me ten
dollars or something like that you know
when I get bored I don't mind playing a
little roulette from time to time I'm
not a [__] degenerate gambler
but I enjoy it so who gives a [__] I
ain't breaking the bank I'm not [__]
uh running from bookies and [__] like
that what a [__] nightmare
back to Boulder no man that that always
sucked it and I always wanted to talk
about that but like when I wrote the
book I I forgot all about that now
I really wanted it to work I thought I
was going to be Johnny white man and
[__] walk on campus and they were
going to love me and I was going to get
straight B's and [__] and my grades
weren't bad I could lie to you and tell
you that you know my grades weren't
[__] bad at all I studied I did my
homework you know I did everything I
could but
if I could do it all over again that's
what I would go for this time the right
way you know what I'm saying I didn't I
don't think I want to be a frat guy like
I was too old to go into a friend [__]
that [__] I don't want to hang out with
20 stinky guys and drink beer out of a
bong and [__] like that I didn't want to
do that but just
you know the cop program that I was in
offered you I mean it was for retouch
guys the cup minority program I was in
it was for retards and part of my
the only thing I had I was a little
ashamed of it because I knew what it was
it was uh I was I was I was a statistic
that's all I was I was a statistic and
at that time CU Boulder had a lot of
problems recruiting players of
minorities
because that's what else they were
talking about this documentary that was
interesting when I got the Bold I think
the second year I got the boulder at 90
25 football players had been arrested
and they didn't know what to do they
were black
they were African-American so the cops
didn't know how to handle them one of
the guys they showed the documentary was
JJ Flanagan I told my wife that guy
saved my life
and JJ Flanagan told the story on there
that he was it was Halloween
and uh
a bunch of white kids attacked them like
they were yelling at him and [__] I mean
this guy's scoring touchdowns every week
and the [__] bold the kids were still
yelling at him and calling [__] the
n-word and [__] then the cops came they
broke it up and he was about to go home
and one of the girls that was with him
called him the [__] n-word and he
held off and smacked her in the [__]
face
there was a lot of problems in Boulder
at that time he smacked her in the face
they arrested him
but they threw it out of court and
because of that they they made a law it
was called the J.J Flanagan law that if
you call somebody a racial slur and the
city limits to Boulder you got one
coming to you
like you got one coming for free like
you could smack that [__] kick
them bite him hit him with a bottle they
won't press charges and that rule saved
my life in 95. that's the reason I'm
here
that's how much [__] they were
getting tortured there was a couple guys
that were real thugs they were [__]
uh
like there was a bookie in Boulder that
had a diner and he was sending these
black kids to beat up [__] white kids
at college campuses that was not good
but these kids were [__] good kids I
knew half of them they were just 20 year
old [__] gorilla football plays
that's it they were the biggest
[__] in the world before I left
Boulder in 95 like I was tight with Chad
Brown the linebacker
and I would go over that and buy weed
from him once a week and he would tell
me you got to stay outside because the
snake is loose he had these [__]
snakes in his house so I would you know
I stayed in it for as long as I could I
I spoke to him I wasn't like a football
brown nose and I didn't give a [__]
about any of that [__] I wasn't going to
play football I was an old man these
guys were [__] real football players
it was just that it kept my spirit up
you know
so all those guys were getting [__]
arrested and I was there for all that
[__] you know I still remember them
getting [__] they had to bring in a
black psychiatrist to get them like they
didn't have any uh other
people at the school there was tons of
rumors going around but they were all
[__] lies they were saying that the
quarterback was selling crack
I knew that [__] guy I knew him well
he would come into the car wash he was
always very nice did he smoke pot maybe
he was from [__] L.A you know he was
from uh downtown L.A whatever the [__]
he was Compton or whatever
but you know man
if you got a chance to go to college if
you're a young [__] kid
you know what I don't give a [__] if you
gotta take loans I mean
take this you know you gotta investigate
and see what the [__] they're giving out
I had a guy that was my [__] roommate
that that's what he did for a living he
got you Pell Grants and [__]
scholarships and and guys it's just a
matter of looking into it and attacking
it it's a lot of letter writing it's a
lot of sending [__] I mean the process
has probably changed today but guys I
was getting a lot of scholarship money I
don't even know how much but I know for
for there was a small window for like
six months
I was getting a check every week
500 to 50 750 and nobody knew about this
[__] like it wasn't that they were like
school money like he would just sign up
I got money from every chat as there is
every Mexican gave me money every Cuban
artist gave me it was [__] crazy you
know and it was a program
to keep you
happy
but that you maintained you needed a 2.0
grade average
that's a d
that's a d you got two to three hours of
tutoring per class per week
so they did everything they could
to you know push you up the ladder which
if you're a [__] immigrant that's the
last thing you want you know there's
some people that like that [__] that
light to just [__] get a d and move
on it wasn't for me that was not I
looked at that D and I'm like
that seems okay but I'm not gonna go to
school to get a [__] d
I'm gonna go to school to at least get
something out of this [__] [__] but
those are the things that kind of made
me ashamed of the program was the D the
tutoring there was like eight other
things that they basically held held
your hands throughout the whole thing
was it cool it was cool but you know
what man people go to school and they
work hard and they study and now you
come in and all you need is a d to get
another scholarship for the next
semester
it just didn't cut right with me but it
was one of those things man that I'll
never
ever forget like I was so proud for a
while when I got out of prison I thought
I was really going to go down the
Scholastic route I thought I was going
to be walking around Boulder with a pipe
you know with Birkenstocks on talking
about engineering and [__] but
it didn't work out for me man and I wish
it would have I always wanted to do
something with law you know and not
listen I go back to school now at 60 and
get like a paralegal and learn how to do
some [__] things but [__] that
[__] that's what I did for 20. oh
paralegal I didn't know that
office
no [__]
you don't want to do it no more
it's horrible you hear all the bad
stories
all the [__] but the people calling you
you got to deal with the people that
can't pay the mortgage you basically
want to go between for the mortgage
company because they don't want to deal
with the people the right home
but I would like to do like uh or
something good like a like a doctor's
office or something no I want to work
with criminals oh yeah I want to work
with [__] criminals
public defender
no I would work for a public defender's
office or work for an attorney's office
but I'd love for it to be in like uh in
law I would love for it to be in like a
criminal A drugs you know [__] like that
that I know about because that makes it
easier you know half of those attorneys
don't get [__] high
so when you're defending somebody you
really kind of get lost that's where I
come in I could be a mouthpiece you know
I can't go up there and testify and say
[__] but I could fill your [__] I
could fill his lip
and let him ask questions that you know
could [__] help him win the case or
whatever the [__] going on here I
always loved that Avenue I thought
somewhere along the line I would [__]
fall into something but again you don't
fall into [__] law okay again Uncle
Joey's being [__] ridiculous here you
don't fall into law you gotta [__] go
in there and uh
just [__] do it but it's so weird
when I was watching that documentary on
that I really wish I could have done a
podcast at that time with the
documentary behind me because it was
just so [__] interesting and I gotta
be honest with you guys
I lived in a lot of places I miss
Boulder
I miss Boulder a lot like I miss walking
around those streets
I miss what it was I mean bold is
completely different now it's grown 10
times since I've been there I don't even
think there's any [__] hippies left
you know
but
I love to go back with my daughter and
my wife not I'm taking a break from the
planes United [__] me up last week I
can't go on no planes for a while I got
PTSD from United Airlines I it's it's
it's over once I saw that dirty
silverware I'm like [__] that [__] I
can't deal with that stuff at all
dirty silverware guys no I can't I gotta
move the [__] on but in time I'm gonna
go back to Boulder and say my goodbyes
you know I've never gone back to bowl
this is 95.
never
didn't even I always when I went back to
Denver to work the Comedy Works I always
said I'm going to take a ride to Boulder
I [__] the bed and Boulder guys
not that somebody would Point me out now
on both I got plenty of friends still in
Boulder I still talk to them I still
keep in touch with them the problem is
me as as Joey Diaz I always felt that I
shipped the bed in Boulder Bowl to open
the I don't know
going into Colorado was like going into
God's country for me it was at 18. I had
gotten my eyes open to a complete
different world that I wouldn't have got
my eyes open to living here all these
[__] do is go to Florida in
Atlantic City you know that's it Jersey
people are going to fly to Atlantic City
that's it that's not me at all I don't
like [__] Florida and Atlantic City
twice a year I could go and I'm happy
so when I went to Colorado for me I
always felt like I was uh
I was living in God's country
you know and then I went there and what
did I do
I [__] kidnapped people I robbed the
university I robbed the town I got
married I [__] [__] that up
I got arrested I went to prison I mean
you know and the hits don't [__] stop
you know it's just don't stop in Boulder
and you know what I usually don't feel
guilty about [__] like I don't give a
[__] what you think this Boulder thing
really bothered me my behavior in
Boulder bothered me
just little things I always try I almost
tried to stab a guy you know it just no
it just guys
Boulder caught me at the wrong time man
I was
the age of 24
to [__] what 24 I got there
in 86.
I went to bowl the first in 83 but just
to look and I swore I never go back
there I went back in 86
and I stayed till 95 in Boulder so
that's nine years
so when I left Boulder I was about 32 or
33 I
even on the way out I I [__] spit on
them because on the way out of Boulder I
had two driver's licenses and I was
going to Ogden Utah
to do my first triple tour
and [__] I was like man I'm short on
money
I got to fill up my gas tank I filled up
my gas tank and I gave the guy my
license and I said I'll be back I left
my wall he goes take your time and I
never went back my life since it was 28
or something like that but again guys
this is what I'm talking about
so it's taken me
5 28 years
to forgive myself over Boulder
and now maybe this year we're thinking
about it this July but I think we're
gonna go next year give the [__]
Airlines a chance to get it together
again and I'm gonna take my daughter and
my wife to Boulder and walk around and
uh you know tell them where I lived and
show them where I went to school and
stuff I don't know maybe I'll open up
her eyes
maybe she'll want to go out there when
she's older but I think
it was a great place it was a great
place for me
till this day I'm very happy I did time
but I'm very ashamed that I did those
things in Boulder and it really really
really [__] bothered me so when I
left there I said you know what I'm
going to take a breathe from Boulder
it's like doing time Boulder is such a
paradise that I took myself out and I
gave myself time like Chris Cornell and
fell on Black Days I just got you know I
had to do it yeah I had to do it so now
I'm ready I paid my [__] due Society
I paid my dues to myself
and then I could go back and walk around
my chin [__] high you know and that's
how I feel
if you ever get a chance to go to
anywhere in Colorado go I don't care if
it's Telluride especially if you live in
a big city or something go to Boulder go
to Telluride see those mountains man
those mountains change my [__] life
they didn't change my life enough to
stop stealing and snorting coke
I still laugh about I had a friend that
used to always go what the [__] are you
doing in Boulder doing Boulders that's
what he would ask me what the [__] are
you doing in Boulder doing boulders
I wish I would have put more of this in
the book my life in Boulder it was
it really I was in with some great
people
I was in with some bad people but I was
in with some great people also but I
still keep in touch with and they're
like [__] family to me and the people
that I was with there that moved away
I still keep in touch with them I have
friends in Mississippi Columbus Ohio
from Boulder I got a guy in Minneapolis
I used to come to my shows at the House
of Comedy I got friends all over from
those days from 1985 in Boulder I still
got [__] friends we're all a bunch of
old sacks of [__] but
but I can't explain I got something out
of Boulder like when you hear all my
stories about growing up my friends in
Jersey it was great I had a blast with
these [__]
but it was nothing
my boldy years added to that I forget
all the people that were in my life like
Danny feeble's and his wife I had some
good [__] friends in Bowling they
were there with me when I started comedy
until this day at least let me tell you
how much I [__] up
for the last 10 years I've been trying
to go back to the boulder broker and I
even had a guy who worked there that
reached out to me and I asked him if he
could put it together I [__] up so
much in Boulder they won't even have me
back at the broker where I [__]
started
comedy work so have me but Bolden
am I ashamed of telling you this [__]
yes I am but the other time I'm proud of
telling you this because I changed my
life now I could walk in there and go
you know what
I did what I had to do I'm back here
I'll go to I go to Chautauqua Park
that's where the gods live
you know I go to
[__] North Hollywood North Boulder
Park I still know I still remember where
uh
the guitar player from the Eagles made a
statue for his daughter when she died
there and I would always go over there
and eat lunch and just sit next to the
Statue not Glenn Frey
not the [__] guy they thrown out but
the guy who joined the Eagles of Rocky
Mountain Way the guy that sings all that
[__] he lived in North he lived in North
Baldwin I lived there and his daughter
died when she was four and he [__]
made like a
a dedication at North Boulder Park
Boulder was very good to me guys and uh
I'm happy that
I changed my life around and that
I go back to Boulder with pride now
and that's the Monday motivation on
[__] May 1st guys
I'm excited this book is coming out
tomorrow
and I'm excited it's over with I put
this to rest I'm gonna do uh Barstool
Sports tomorrow when the book gets
released
and then I'll keep you guys post on the
book signings I haven't heard [__] I
told her about this a month ago and I
haven't heard [__] I haven't heard
anything on New Jersey 12. I was trying
to get on New Jersey 12. because I went
to the gym the other day and I saw one
of my friends Bill Bellamy put out a
book and he was on [__] New York live
and I'm like
I don't even want to get on New York
live I don't want to do any of those
shows but I would like to go on New
Jersey 12 and talk some [__] and you
know put down a Ponte restaurant with
Erica and just talk some [__] so I'll
keep you guys posted on that but there's
something else I want to talk to you
about
laughing gas has done it again guys
I've been with laughing gas for two
years now and everything
they sent me a little [__] bud last
week of this
Neptune or something runs or something
like that holy [__] didn't send me
enough of it I would have gave you some
I was [__] up and now they release
these [__] you ready out of
respect for the book tremendous I have
collaborated
and we've got you ready for this
[__]
bam
tremendous
gummies we also have white truffle
gummies we also have cocoa gummies we
also have [__] rainbow Rush gummies
we got them all but this is tremendous
out of respect for the book coming out
tomorrow you can order these we'll
deliver these to you there are 175
milligrams
and 175 of live resin
these do something to you a little
differently than what you're used to but
who the [__] am I go to laughing gas dot
Co and all of these [__] you're
gonna be [__] happy you didn't as
usual the weed is stronger than ever
they're [__] tremendous and I love
them but go to Laughing Gas Co and take
a look at these [__] monsters I gave
my man Mike he's one of the first
victims I gave him some white truffle
ones this week and we're gonna get the
[__] party started re right because
it's celebration week so I'll be around
smoking dope Tuesday I'm doing bar stool
I'm gonna stop in North Jersey and get
some lunch with my friend and then I got
a softball game Tuesday night my
daughter so we can't celebrate nothing
but I'll let you know if I do something
locally in Marlboro Manalapan
something like that that you guys could
stop by I'm still waiting here
on the Book Company in Park Ridge
and I'm still waiting to hear from
[__] New Brunswick and Freehold
and also Philadelphia Barnes and Nobles
how's that to you [__] because
how are you going to release a book with
our [__] Barnes and Nobles how
am I going to release a book if I don't
go down to Philadelphia and say hello
what kind of varmint would I be if I
didn't go down to Philadelphia and say
hello so that's one of the stops I
definitely want to go to don't [__] with
me because I'm bringing [__] mace and
everything else [__] you guys are
affiliate Savages but I love you
[__] Hey listen man
thank you very much for uh letting me
come on here we can talk [__] I know
it's not what you [__] expected
but it is what it is for right now I'm
trying my best I'm just happy it's all
behind me you know
the church was [__] three years ago
man and it still lives and I'm still
tight with Lee and uh whatever people
thought about why we closed it down
listen I knew that this was coming I
knew better days were coming we had to
get out of there and
everything changed for everybody at
least doing great Mike's doing great and
I'm doing great but I gotta thank you
guys for always having all three of our
backs and whatever Ventures we're doing
so thank you you know listen the podcast
is what it is I come up here I talk some
[__] I tell a story and we abandon [__]
what do you want me to keep you here all
day and try to make believe I'm a genius
that I'm not I'm no [__] genius
but just remember
it's a new month with a whole new set of
rules and only you [__] control it
I love you [__] have a great
week stay black
and I'll see you next Monday
Tip Top [__] Magoo and now for
a worth my [__] sponsor Jack
all right guys thank you for listening
today thank you for supporting me don't
forget to go to laughing gas dot Co and
get these [__] devil gummies oh my
God
350 milligrams per jar anyway smoking
weed doesn't have to hurt your lungs
with freeze pipe you save your lungs and
you get a nice cold hit every time
here's how it works you put the
detachable chamber in the freezer give
it an hour when you're ready to rip one
you attach it to the bung and baboon
[__] tremendous you won't feel
nothing you won't cough your throat
won't be sore you'll say what the [__]
is this this is like [__] cryotherapy
for my lungs it's non-toxic it freezes
more quickly than water and it stays
Frozen for longer freeze pipe cools down
the Smoke by 300 [__] degrees
no more burning no more coughing your
throat will thank you whether you hit a
pipe a bubbler a bung or a dab
freeze pipe has got it all so do me a
favor go to thefreeze pipe.com again
thefreeze pipe.com pressing code Diaz
and save 10 off your first order get
your bung pipe or bubbler today if you
can smoke it freeze pipe will [__]
make it that's how we roll the joint is
also brought to you by stamps.com listen
whether you own a small business or a
big business you and I both know every
penny counts why are you messing around
with stamps.com I'm going to save you
time and money on postage with premium
discounts and great rates all you need
is a computer and a printer to print
your own stamps at home like George
Washington no waiting in long lines at
the post office to leave and send you a
free scale who's better than stamps.com
nobody I've been with them for close to
15 years my wife had to send out
packages this week it made it so easy so
and they also have they're gonna run
they're gonna [__] give you a
discount a huge discount on USPS and UPS
plus to automatically tell you the
cheapest and fastest shipping options
who else does that nobody so set your
business up for Success when you get
started with stamp.com today use promo
code Joey no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamp.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
then to code Joey it's that simple I
want to thank stamps.com I want to thank
the freeze pipe and I want to thank
DraftKings for making this possible for
you I love you [__] stay black
have a great week and I'll see you next
Monday tip top Magoo
foreign
[Music]